und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend die Debatte über die
Lieferung von Taurus Marschflugkörpern
an die Ukraine geht weiter die Russen
setzen solche Cruise Missiles übrigens
regelmäßig ein und auch Raketen die
mehrere hundert Kilometer weit fliegen
können die kindschale zum Beispiel mit
der sie heute wieder auf kiefzielten für
näher gelegene Ziele genügen aber auch
die S300 die sie von russischen
Territorium aus unbehelligt etwa auf die
Universitätsstadt hackeschießen hat man
bei Luftalarm gerade mal 40 Sekunden
Zeit bis zum Einschlag da kann man sich
nicht mehr schützen da kann man nur noch
beten auch weiter im Süden in saporisia
ist die russische Besatzungsarmee sehr
nah zwei jungen Mädchen wurde das jetzt
zum Verhängnis Annegret Oster berichtet
Christina und Svetlana sie singen auf
den Straßen von saporizia um Geld zu
sammeln für ukrainischer Soldaten eine
Stunde später
trifft eine russische Rakete das
Stadtzentrum esvetlana ist sofort tot
Christina stirbt einen Tag später im
Krankenhaus
zivile Ziele an was ja hey bleib bei uns
dieser Mann wird nicht gerettet werden
können er stirbt an seinen schweren
Verletzungen nachdem sein Wohnhaus in
Hassan attackiert wurde
und gestern ein zielgerichteter Angriff
auf ein Hotel
wieder in saporicia ein Mensch stirbt 14
werden verletzt darunter auch Kinder
Russland attackiert die Ukraine wird
sich weiter und bitte dafür und nur
dafür um Taurus Marschflugkörper
in diesem Krieg akzeptiert die Ukraine
die Normen des internationalen Rechts
wie Kriege zu führen sind das bedeutet
dass die Ukraine sich nur auf ihrem
Territorium verteidigt unser
strategisches Ziel ist die Befreiung
unserer von den Russen besetzten Gebiete
hier in der Don jetzt Region kämpft die
fünfte slobohansbrigade mit
Raketenwerfern jeden Tag gäbe es
Angriffe der russener zählen sie und
werden zynisch
ein Kamerad sagte mal danke an alle die
das Militär bestochen und sich dann
abgesetzt haben dank euch wissen wir nun
wie wahre Männer nicht aussehen
sie alle hoffen dass der Krieg bald
vorbei sein wird
und dann will ich nach Hause
da weiß ich die Russen von ihren
irdischen goldtaten mit einer Mondfahrt
ablenken zum ersten Mal seit fast fünf
Jahrzehnten schickt Moskau wieder eine
Sonde zum Mond eine Demonstration
technischer Stärke der Großmacht sein
will muss auch ins Weltall am Körper
berichtet
sie hatten es immer wieder versucht
heute läuft alles glatt vom neu gebauten
Weltraumbahnhof war tot Schnee startet
Luna 25 Richtung Mond allen westlichen
Sanktionen zum Trotz
lassen sie uns ehrlich sein die Flüge
zum Mond hatten doch immer eine
politische Komponente nun wer da der
erste ist der ist sozusagen besser als
die die zweiten sind
zweimal nimmt die Trägerrakete Schwung
rund um die Erde und macht sich dann
erst auf den Weg Richtung Mond schwenkt
nach etwa vier Tagen auf dessen
Umlaufbahn ein landen soll sie in der
wenig erforschten Südpolregion die liegt
immer im Schatten ist sehr uneben und
voller Krater sechs Tage nehmen sich die
Russen Zeit um den besten Landepunkt zu
finden
wir suchen einen neuen Landeplatz wo
niemand je gewesen ist ich hoffe dass
wir die Ersten sein werden
12 April 1961 mit dem Russen Juri
Gagarin schreibt die Sowjetunion
Geschichte im bettlauf um das All daran
erinnert Präsident Putin am Jahrestag
als er für die Zukunft große Ziele
ausgibt
wir werden eine eigene Raumstation
aufbauen als Außenposten unseres Landes
im All doch die irdischen
Herausforderungen dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen
in etwa zehn Tagen soll die Sonde auf
dem Mond landen in Zeiten größter
Verunsicherung sucht Putins Reich die
Vergewisserung seiner selbst in den
unendlichen Weiten des Weltraums
auf Hawaii steigt die Zahl der Toten
mindestens 55 Menschen sind bei den
verheerenden Bränden ums Leben gekommen
viele weitere werden noch vermisst
amerikanische Wissenschaftler verweisen
darauf dass es auch eine Folge des
Klimawandels sei dass sich die Feuer so
unkontrollierbar und rasend schnell
ausbreiten konnten dort Falle inzwischen
bis zu einem Drittel weniger Regen als
noch vor 30 Jahren zugleich sind die
Temperaturen gestiegen die Vegetation
Hawaiis habe sich verändert die Brände
verursache in der Regel war der Mensch
aber sie könnten sich leichter
ausbreiten als früher in feuchten
Regenwäldern David sauer Bericht
hieß Hunter hat sein Leben auf Maui
verbracht aber so etwas hat er noch nie
gesehen niemand hier hat das diese
Mondlandschaft war vor Tagen noch in
malerischer Urlaubsort und die Heimat
von 17.000 Menschen in laha
die Menschen haben alles verloren Häuser
Arbeitsplätze Autos manche auch Ihre
Haustiere und es werden immer noch
Menschen vermisst
Polizei Feuerwehr und freiwillige suchen
nach diesen vermissten und nach toten
von mehr als 1.000 Menschen fehlt jedes
Lebenszeichen jeder Kontakt
Gouverneur Josh Green ist vor Ort will
ansprechbar sein er macht sich ein Bild
helfen kann auch er gerade nicht
ich bin die ganze Frontstreet entlang
gelaufen das hier ist was
außergewöhnliches alles ist einfach
verschwunden wir wissen dass viele
Menschen leiden und dass wir heute
weitere Opfer zählen werden
es gab keine Warnungen jedenfalls nicht
rechtzeitig etliche Menschen gingen in
Todesangst in den Ozean die Flammen
hatten sie völlig unvorbereitet
getroffen um Hilfe zu erleichtern hat
das Weiße Haus den Katastrophenfall
ausgerufen
wir stellen Bundesmittel bereit um
schnell vor Ort zu sein und bei der
Arbeit zu helfen die für den
Wiederaufbau notwendig ist und zur
Unterstützung der Menschen vor Ort
von Pearl Harbor auf der Nachbarinsel
starten die ersten Flieger mit
Hilfsgütern die Nationalgarde soll jetzt
helfen
und jetzt die Nachrichten von Heinz Wolf
die Zahl der Firmen Pleiten in
Deutschland nimmt weiter zu laut
Statistischen Bundesamt stieg die Zahl
der beantragten regelinsolvenzen im Juli
umfasst ein Viertel gegenüber dem
Vorjahresmonat das Statistische
Bundesamt bekam heute auch Besuch von
Bundeskanzler Scholz anlässlich des
75-jährigen Bestehens Scholz würdigte
dass das Statistikamt ein umfangreiches
aktuelles und qualitativ hochwertiges
Datenangebot zur Verfügung stelle
in den ersten sieben Monaten dieses
Jahres ist nach Angaben der
Grenzschutzagentur Frontex die Zahl der
festgestellten irregulären
Grenzübertritte an den EU-Außengrenzen
um 13% auf
176.100 gestiegen das sei für diesen
Zeitabschnitt der höchste Wert seit 2016
die meist genutzte Route Richtung EU sei
dabei über das zentrale Mittelmeer
im Fall des Sohns von US-Präsident
beiden hat das Justizministerium einen
Sonderermittler eingesetzt
Untersuchungen gegen den 53-Jährigen
Hunter beiden laufen seit geraumer Zeit
wegen Verstößen gegen das Steuer-
vor der Küste Jemens ist es unter
Leitung der Vereinten Nationen gelungen
in einer hochgefährlichen Aktion rund
160 Millionen Liter Öl von einem
rostigen Tanker abzupumpen und damit
eine Umweltkatastrophe abzuwenden das
lange als schwimmendes Lager genutzte
Schiff drohte auseinander zu brechen das
war seit 2015 nach Beginn des
Bürgerkriegs nicht mehr gewartet worden
bei der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft stehen
die ersten beiden halbfinal-teams Fest
zum einen Spanien durch einen 2:1
Viertelfinalsieg gegen die Niederlande
zum anderen Schweden das 2:1 gegen Japan
gewonnen hat Zusammenfassungen von allen
Spielen diese WM finden Sie bei uns in
der ZDF heute App und morgen geht die WM
Viertelfinale Runde weiter zu sehen im
ZDF ab 8:30 Uhr noch kurz die
Wetteraussichten morgen ziehen von
Westen Schauer und Gewitter auf teils
mit Starkregen und Sturmböen abends
erreichen Sie den Osten und Süden die
Temperatur steigt auf schwül war mit 22
bis 31 Grad die kommenden Tage bringen
Schauer und Gewitter mit Unwetter
Gefahren am freundlichsten ist es im
Nordwesten dort liegen die Höchstwerte
bei 22 Grad und in Bayern werden 31 Grad
erreicht ja das war es das schon von uns
bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]